si vous ne savez toujours pas quoi
offrir vous pouvez offrir des cadeaux
locaux avec des artisans Yvelines noires
Régine vous en avez sélectionné
quelques-uns vie et pour régaler les
fans d'histoire et de senteurs je vous
propose de découvrir la marque og elle
se situe à Montainville et c'est la
créatrice Pascale Oger qui a voulu
redonner vie à des parfums des senteurs
et même des objets ayant appartenu à des
célèbres personnages français elle
propose donc une gamme de bougies et de
parfum d'intérieur d'époque je vous
propose d'y jeter un œil
c'est le parfum du domaine de Madame
Élisabeth le parfum Madame Elisabeth qui
existe en bougie et un parfum
d'intérieur c'est un parfum en fait qui
a été dédié qui a été rattaché au
domaine de Madame Elisabeth il reprend
trois huiles essentielles très
caractéristiques du XVIIIe siècle la
fleur d'oranger la rose de Damas et le
tilleul
et pour pimenter votre réveillon de Noël
je vous propose un cadeau très original
une sauce piquante made in Viroflay
cette sauce est l'initiative de la
famille Martin qui voudrait mettre à mal
une légende qui insinuerait que les
Français n'aiment pas le piment les
créateurs de la marque Anna
Jean-Baptiste et Benjamin ont donc cocu
concocté des sauces qui je suis qui je
cite promettrait de mettre le feu au
sapin je vous laisse regarder et qu'une
chose qu'à base de piment à bannero il
est fermenté pendant à peu près deux ans
en fût et après on cuisine les sauces et
alors là vous avez ça en bouche vous
avez quelque chose d'extraordinaire de
fruité et de brûlant à souhait vous
mettez ça sous le sapin et vous allez
mettre le feu au sapin
et donc on le voit ils sont également
déguisés en piment c'était une volonté
de c'était sa volonté mais moi justement
j'ai une question vous êtes plutôt qu'en
douceur parfum bougie ou plutôt vous
êtes attiré par les saveurs un peu
piquantes
alors moi le piment
on va pimenter le réveillon j'ai pas la
sauce piquante en tête mais bon ouais
mais pourquoi pas c'est une idée
originale avec plusieurs gammes et en
plus oui une sauce locale c'est ça aussi
mais c'est très intéressant mais moi je
vous propose de mettre un peu d'épices
voilà
des pistes un petit peu mais pas trop
quand même pas trop